i have to ask you about hamilton i'm
sure you get asked about it
all the time but i am a new fan because
i wouldn't let myself listen to anything
until i could see the show and fall and
thankfully that happened because of
disney plus
right when you first auditioned for the
show was it just
any old audition to you at that point or
did you know
that i don't know it could go on to
become a phenomenon
um to be completely honest i almost
didn't audition
because on paper it sounded like
ridiculous
i was like a contemporary musical
involving like pop r b hip hop and rap
music
about the like the founding fathers of
our country
and like the the like beginnings of our
financial system
i just was like who would see that
and i think everybody we all felt that
way and so i had just come back from
being on tour with wicked
and i think this was a moment for me
where i was like well here's an
opportunity for a thing that's going to
broadway
and i can like sit down and start laying
some roots and and so that was really
appealing to me but also i was as as
like
as much as i didn't understand it i was
also really intrigued by it because
obviously it's
lynn and then tommy and and andy and
it's the whole in the heights crew and
and they just you know their their work
is amazing and
speaks for itself and so i was obviously
the opportunity to work with that
group it um was really enticing and um
the audition process was not it was
quick because um
you know they had previously been at the
public for three months and after the
public
they added four ensemble tracks um and
so i was one of those tracks and so they
had a couple weeks before they started
rehearsals for broadway where they
needed to cast
these new these new ensemble members um
and so that's what was one of the tracks
that i was going in for
um and yeah i think it um it was it was
quick because i think i had i was given
i was sent the material by my agents and
i think i had
24 hours and in 24 hours i had to learn
um helpless satisfied say no to this
and i think and and burn and like
in 24 hours i had to learn how to rap i
had to
memorize all this music that i'd never
heard before and i think the best part
about it and i
i think it is in a dropbox somewhere on
some computer that i have
but there was no recordings there wasn't
the album there was nothing to
i was literally having to like look at
this stuff and figure out it just it was
it was like music i'd never i'd never
learned music like that before
um and so they also sent along mp3s of
lynne playing and singing the songs and
it is
some of the best content there is and i
um and i it's he's he like he always
is just like so committed singing full
out
the emotion is there and it's just like
lin singing
burn it's just like so good um and i
just i can't
find them and i really wish i could they
probably pulled them because they just
were like these can never get out
but um i don't know how i crammed all
that information into my brain
but i also think i instantly connected
with the material and the way that
people have all over the world and the
reason it's become such a phenomenon and
it's there's just like something
everyone can connect to it
and so i think i think i had that same
reaction when i was learning the
material
it just like as hard as it was i
couldn't help but continue to just like
devour it i just was like oh my god i
want more like what
i thought this was going to be weird but
this is like these songs are
freaking amazing
you